قياس التراكب الكمي عشوائي مثل رمي عملة معدنية لكن إلى أي مدى يمكننا أخذ هذا التشبيه
قبل أن ينهار سنكتشف اليوم في Qiskit في
الفصل الدراسي مرحباً بكم في Qiskit في الفصل الدراسي سلسلة فيديو نشرح فيها مفهوماً أساسياً قد
تصادفونه في مقرر متعلق بالحوسبة الكمية كل فيديو مصحوب بوحدة تفاعلية مرتبطة في
الوصف أدناه فتأكدوا من الاطلاع عليها اليوم نتحدث عن أحد المبادئ الأساسية في قلب
النظرية الكمية التراكب في تجربتنا اليومية الأشياء دائماً لها خصائص محددة موقعها وحجمها
وشكلها ولونها كل شيء عنها محدد ومؤكد حتى لو لم نقسه بعد كمراقبين في
العالم الكمي هذا ليس بالضرورة هو الحال يمكن أن يكون الجسم الكمي في شيء يُسمى تراكب
حالات متعددة مسموحة كلاسيكياً والذي عند قياسه سينهار عشوائياً إلى إحدى تلك
الحالات قياس حالة التراكب مثل رمي عملة لا توجد طريقة لمعرفة مسبقاً على أي وجه ستسقط
هذا اللاحتمية الجوهرية هي جانب مزعج من ميكانيكا الكم حتى Einstein واجه صعوبة
معها فقد قال عبارته الشهيرة الله لا يلعب النرد عن هذه العشوائية لكن كما سنرى الله فعلاً يلعب النرد أو في
حالتنا يرمي العملات لكن أكثر من ذلك هذه العملات مُثقّلة قياس التراكب الكمي قد يشبه
رمي عملة من بعض النواحي لكن التراكب نفسه أغنى وأعقد بكثير من حالة احتمالية
كلاسيكية لنرى هذا سنفكر في كيفية عمل عملة كلاسيكية ونقارنها مع عملتنا
الكمية التي سنستكشفها باستخدام Qiskit على حاسوب IBM الكمي أولاً العملة الكلاسيكية الأمر
بسيط جداً ترمي العملة وتسقط إما وجه أو ظهر باحتمال 50% لكل منهما حسناً من حيث المبدأ يمكننا
حساب أي وجه ستسقط عليه العملة إذا عرفنا الظروف الابتدائية الدقيقة للعملة وبالضبط كم من
القوة وعزم الدوران طُبقا أثناء الرمي لكن عملياً لا توجد طريقة لمعرفة مسبقاً أي وجه ستسقط
عليه العملة لذلك نستخدم رمي العملة كمثال نموذجي لحالة احتمالية كلاسيكية حيث
النتيجة عشوائية أساساً لو رميت هذه العملة ألف مرة وسجلت عدد مرات الوجه
والظهر سأحصل على مدرج تكراري يبدو تقريباً هكذا لدينا العدد على المحور
العمودي ويمكن أن تكون إما وجه أو ظهر و
المدرج التكراري سيُظهر أن هناك حوالي 500 عدد لكل منهما مع بعض
التذبذب الإحصائي يمكننا إنشاء حالة مشابهة باستخدام qubit على حاسوبنا الكمي مثل رمي العملة
الـ qubit أيضاً يمكن قياسه في حالتين ممكنتين صفر وواحد إذا طبقنا شيئاً يُسمى gate Hadamard على
الـ qubit سيضعه في تراكب متساوٍ من صفر وواحد إليكم
تصويراً لتلك الـ circuit التي نسميها مخطط circuit هنا السلك العلوي هو
الـ qubit والعمليات المطبقة على الـ qubit تظهر كمربعات على الأسلاك gate الـ Hadamard تُظهر بهذا المربع
المسمى H والقياس يُظهر بهذا المربع الرمادي المسمى برمز القياس الصغير ويرسل ذلك
القياس إلى بت كلاسيكي هذا السلك بخطين فبما أن الـ qubit في تراكب متساوٍ من 0 و1 عندما
نقيسه سيكون هناك احتمال 50% أن نقيس صفراً و50% أن نقيس
واحداً نعبر عن حالة التراكب الكمي هذه كـ psi = 1/جذر
2 ضرب 0 + 1/جذر 2 ضرب 1 حيث مربعات كل من هذه
المعاملات التي تُسمى أيضاً سعات هي احتمالات قياس كل حالة ففعلياً تطبيق gate الـ Hadamard
هو المقابل لرمي العملة وكما رمينا العملة ألف مرة لننظر في
إحصائيات سقوط العملة على الوجه أو الظهر يمكننا فعل شيء مشابه على Qiskit مع عملتنا الكمية
سنستخدم أداة Qiskit الأساسية تُسمى sampler التي ستكرر الـ circuit عدة مرات لأخذ عينات من إحصائيات
الحالة الناتجة مع ألف عينة من الـ circuit أعلاه لدينا شيء يبدو مطابقاً أساساً
للمدرج التكراري للعملة الكلاسيكية مع بعض التذبذب الإحصائي فهل هذا كل شيء التراكبات
الكمية هي أساساً نفس الحالة الاحتمالية الكلاسيكية شبيهة برمي عملة ليس تماماً سيكون هذا
فيديو قصيراً جداً لو كان الحال كذلك لنرى أول فرق رئيسي سأجرب شيئاً مختلفاً قليلاً مع عملتي الكلاسيكية بدلاً
من تركها تسقط ببساطة على الطاولة لتستقر على الوجه أو الظهر سأرمي العملة وألتقطها
في الهواء بين كفّي الآن العملة ليست وجه أو ظهر بل هي إما رأس لليسار
أو لليمين فالمنطق يقول لنا أن هذا أيضاً يجب أن يكون له احتمال 50/50 أن يكون
إما رأس لليسار أو لليمين لقياس رأس لليسار أو لليمين على عملتنا الكمية يمكننا فعل ما فعلناه مع العملة الكلاسيكية
القياس على محور مختلف قياساتنا المعتادة على الحاسوب الكمي هي على المحور العمودي
تماماً مثل قياس الوجه والظهر المعتاد للعملة الكلاسيكية لكن يمكننا أيضاً سؤال عملتنا الكمية هل هي
رأس لليسار أو لليمين نسمي هاتين الحالتين على محور X زائد أو ناقص
لهذا نستخدم أداة Qiskit الأساسية المسماة estimator ولتعقيد الأمور قليلاً بدلاً من إرجاع مدرج تكراري مثل
sampler فإن estimator يعطينا ما يُسمى القيمة المتوقعة لأي مُقاس للـ qubit لفهم
هذه القيمة المتوقعة لنقل أنك تكسب دولاراً كل مرة تسقط العملة على الوجه وتخسر دولاراً عندما تسقط
على الظهر القيمة المتوقعة هي كم من المال يمكنك توقع كسبه في المتوسط مع كل رمية عملة بما أنك
من المرجح بالتساوي أن تكسب أو تخسر دولاراً فالقيمة المتوقعة ستكون صفراً نفس المنطق يمكن تطبيقه
على الـ qubit عندما نجد القيمة المتوقعة لـ X عندما نطبق X على حالة الزائد
نحصل على القيمة +1 وعلى حالة الناقص نحصل على -1 فلو كان لدينا
توزيع 50/50 لحصلنا على قيمة متوقعة صفر لكننا لا نحصل على ذلك نحصل على قيمة متوقعة +1
مما يعني أن العملة تُقاس دائماً لتكون زائد على محور X وهذا يكون مثل رمي
عملة والتقاطها وضمان أن الرأس سيكون دائماً متجهاً لليمين وهذا لأن
التراكب ليس مجرد توزيع احتمالي تذكروا كيف نعبر عن الحالة
الكمية psi تساوي c0 ضرب الحالة 0 زائد c1
ضرب الحالة 1 حيث كل من هذه المعاملات عقدية مما يعني أن لها
أجزاء حقيقية وتخيلية فهي تخبرنا عن الاحتمالات لكنها تخفي أيضاً كمية أخرى تُسمى
الطور يمكن كتابة معامل ما c هكذا
حيث c يساوي المقدار ضرب هذا الطور حيث phi هذا هو
الطور إنه يشبه قليلاً طور موجة أو موقع قمم وقيعان الموجة إذا كانت موجتان في نفس الطور
مع بعضهما بحيث تتراصف قممهما وقيعانهما فستتحدان لتشكلا موجة بضعف
الارتفاع نسمي هذا التداخل البنّاء إذا كانتا في طور معاكس
هكذا فإنهما تتداخلان هدمياً وتلغيان بعضهما تماماً لنرى كيف يمكن للطور أن يسبب
تداخلاً في عملتنا الكمية لنجرب تطبيق Hadamard مرتين بدلاً من مرة واحدة كلاسيكياً
هذا لن يكون منطقياً إذا كان تطبيق Hadamard مكافئاً لرمي عملة فلا يمكنك رمي عملة تتقلب بالفعل لكن لنرى ما
يحدث كمياً فنطبق Hadamard مرتين ونأخذ عينات من الحالة الناتجة
بشكل مذهل لم يعد لدينا احتمال 50/50 المدرج التكراري الناتج يُظهر أنه في كل حالة نقيس
الـ qubit ليكون في حالة الصفر فالـ Hadamard الثاني أعاد الـ qubit إلى حالة الصفر التي بدأنا منها
من الصعب قليلاً رؤيته في البداية لكن هذا بفضل تداخل الحالة الكمية لكن بدلاً من
التداخل في الفضاء الحقيقي كموجة فعلية فإن التداخل يحدث في فضاء المعلومات المجرد للـ qubit
gate الـ Hadamard الثاني تسبب في أن يتداخل جزء الصفر من التراكب بنّاءً بينما جزء الواحد من
التراكب تداخل هدمياً واختفى لنستكشف أكثر يمكننا تغيير الطور باستخدام
شيء يُسمى gate الطور فالآن لنطبق Hadamard لإنشاء التراكب ثم نطبق إزاحة طورية بمقدار
pi راديان ثم نطبق Hadamard الثاني الآن يبدو أن عملتنا الكمية تخرج دائماً في حالة الواحد
إزاحة الطور بمقدار pi بدّلت أجزاء حالة التراكب التي كانت في نفس الطور ومعاكسة الطور مع بعضها
فالحالة النهائية هي واحد بدلاً من صفر وهذا يكون مثل رمي عملة وبينما هي في الهواء التمكن
من تطبيق عملية ما تضمن أنها تسقط دائماً على الوجه أو دائماً على الظهر حسب
العملية مستحيل في الحالة الكلاسيكية لكن ليس في الحالة الكمية ما تعلمناه من هذه التجارب هو
أن هذه القدرة الجديدة للعملة الكمية ترجع إلى طورها وهي خاصية يمتلكها التراكب الكمي لكن
التوزيع الاحتمالي الكلاسيكي لا يمتلكها فرمي العملة المعتاد ليس في الحقيقة تشبيهاً جيداً جداً للتراكب
لأنه لا يقول شيئاً عن هذا الطور أعتقد أننا نستطيع أن نفعل أفضل سأجري تجربة أخرى
مع عملتنا لدي العملة جالسة على الطاولة على الوجه لجعلها على الظهر يمكنني ببساطة قلبها هذا
هو المكافئ الحسابي لـ gate NOT لنقل أننا نريد بناء عملية إذا طُبقت مرتين ستكون
مكافئة لـ gate NOT يمكننا تسمية هذه العملية جذر NOT إذاً فكروا فيما نفعله فيزيائياً
عندما نطبق gate NOT نحن ندير العملة 180 درجة حول محور X مثلاً فلو أدرنا العملة
90 درجة فقط حول محور X لأعطانا ذلك جذر NOT فقد طبقنا
جذر NOT والعملة تجلس على حافتها الآن يمكننا أن نسأل هل هي وجه أم ظهر حسناً
من الواضح أنها لا هذا ولا ذاك لكن يمكننا إضافة خطوة لعملية القياس لإجبارها أن تكون وجه أو ظهر الآن
العملة ستسقط على جانب الوجه أو الظهر باحتمال متساوٍ مرة أخرى من حيث المبدأ يمكننا التنبؤ
بأي اتجاه ستسقط لكن عملياً هذا صعب بما يكفي للتنبؤ لجعله عشوائياً أساساً إذا أردت
قياس ما إذا كانت رأس لليسار أو لليمين يمكنني سحقها في ذلك الاتجاه بطريقة مشابهة وستعطينا مرة أخرى
احتمال 50/50 لليسار واليمين لكن في هذا البعد رأس للأمام أو للخلف
الرأس يواجه بالفعل الأمام فـ 100% من الوقت سنقيسها رأس للأمام فبينما قياسات X و Z
أعطت نتائج عشوائية قياس Y سيعطي دائماً نفس النتيجة إذا فكرنا في تجربة
العملة الكمية من القسم السابق فهذا يذكرنا بكيفية تصرف العملة الكمية بعد
تطبيق Hadamard الـ qubit قيس ليكون إما صفر أو 1 باحتمال 50/50 في اتجاه Z لكن
دائماً حالة الزائد وأبداً حالة الناقص على محور X هذا يقترح أن ربما عملة واقفة ساكنة على
حافتها هي طريقة أفضل لتصور حالة تراكب الـ qubit من عملة تتقلب بجنون في الهواء
لنطبق gate جذر NOT على عملتنا الكمية في Qiskit لدينا هذه الـ circuit
البسيطة ثم سنستخدم estimator للتحقق من القيمة المتوقعة لثلاثة مُقاسات X و Y و Z وهي نوعاً ما
مثل إسقاط عملتنا على كل من الأبعاد الثلاثة كما أريتكم للتو فالقيم المتوقعة هي 0
و -1 و 0 لـ X و Y و Z على التوالي وهذه نفس النتيجة التي
حصلنا عليها لدوران جذر NOT المطبق على العملة الكلاسيكية في الواقع هناك تشبيه دقيق بين
العملة وحالة الـ qubit الآن يمكننا تصور حالة الـ qubit كمتجه يشير في اتجاه الرأس
على العملة عمودياً على سطح العملة فالوجه أي حالة الصفر
على العملة الكمية يكافئ متجهاً يشير لأعلى مباشرةً والظهر أو الواحد يشير لأسفل مباشرةً وأي
تراكب متساوٍ من 0 و1 يشير أفقياً طور الحالة الكمية يحدد الاتجاه الأفقي الدقيق
الذي يشير إليه مثلاً ما إذا كان يشير على محور X أو على محور Y أو في مكان
بينهما هذا المتجه يُعرف بمتجه Bloch وهو يحدد بشكل كامل وفريد الحالة الكمية لـ qubit
واحد يمكننا الآن إعادة تخيل كل gate رأيناها في هذا الفيديو كدوران أو سلسلة دورانات على
العملة أو بالمقابل على متجه Bloch gate الـ NOT هي دوران بمقدار
180 درجة حول محور X عند تطبيقها على حالة الصفر أو الوجه تقلبها إلى
حالة الظهر أو الواحد جذر NOT هو 90 درجة فقط حول نفس محور X بدءاً
من حالة الوجه تديرها إلى الرأس للأمام gate الطور هي دوران بمقدار phi حول محور Z بما أن
الوجه محاذٍ لمحور Z فهذا لا يفعل شيئاً للعملة gate الـ Hadamard أصعب قليلاً
شبّهناها في البداية برمي عملة تجعل العملة تدور بلا سيطرة في الهواء لكن Hadamard هي في الحقيقة
دوران محدد وحتمي للعملة مثل كل الـ gate الأخرى Hadamard تُنفَّذ بالدوران 90 درجة
حول محور Y ثم 180 درجة حول محور X فعند تطبيقها على حالة الوجه
تنتهي بكونها رأس لليمين فلا يوجد شيء عشوائي في حالة التراكب الكمي أو في أي من
العمليات المعتادة التي نجريها على الـ qubit كل عملية حتمية وقابلة للعكس المرة الوحيدة
التي تدخل فيها العشوائية هي عندما نقرر قياس الحالة الكمية ما إذا كانت الحالة الكمية في
تراكب أصلاً هو في الحقيقة مجرد وجهة نظر المراقب كما صادفتم على الأرجح نحن أحرار في اختيار
نظام الإحداثيات الخاص بنا X و Y و Z يمكن أن يشيروا في أي ثلاثة اتجاهات متعامدة فإذا
كان لدينا تراكب من 0 و1 في نظام إحداثيات واحد يمكننا تعريف نظام إحداثيات جديد أو ما يُسمى
أساساً جديداً تكون فيه الحالة تشير بحتاً في اتجاه Z الموجب وبالتالي ليست في حالة تراكب
فعندما نقول أن qubit في حالة تراكب يجب أيضاً أن نعرّف نظام إحداثياتنا أو
أساسنا قد تغادرون هذه الوحدة بانطباع أننا أزلنا كل الغموض من ميكانيكا الكم
فبعد كل شيء أحد أغرب الجوانب المفترضة وهي حالة تراكب الـ qubit هي في الحقيقة بسيطة مثل
متجه ثلاثي الأبعاد لكن تذكروا أن العملة لا تزال مجرد تشبيه وحتى متجه Bloch هو
مجرد أداة تصور لحساب احتمالات نتائج القياس لا نستطيع القول ما تفعله الحالة الكمية
حقاً قبل قياسها لأن التحقق من ذلك يتطلب قياساً سنناقش هذه
المعضلة حول ما هي الطبيعة الحقيقية للحالة الكمية وكيف يمكن لظاهرة التشابك الكمي أن تساعدنا
في توضيح هذا في حلقة أخرى من Qiskit في الفصل الدراسي كلها عن متباينة Bell في هذه الأثناء إذا
أردتم اللعب بالعملات الكمية لتتعلموا بأنفسكم عن حالات تراكب الـ qubit وكيفية التحكم
فيها توجهوا إلى وحدة العملات الكمية المرتبطة في الوصف شكراً للمشاهدة وأراكم في المرة القادمة